just you know three
four five six left foot goes over the
body I'm staying low turning around
oh okay and I'm gonna go this way
okay
um okay so my question is why do we have
these classes coming up when we don't
have finishing schools coming up when
most women can't cook
so actually you know that's more of a
statement but I'm gonna ask you guys
would you send your girl to that
wow
I'm not very funny
but I've never I've never had sex with a
second potato so no I'm not saying to my
girlfriend
what kind of clock
she had a count
like why do you need account that's
that's my opening argument
you sending your girl
um probably not but I've given props for
trying but
it's a bit shocking to think they've had
to learn it yo it's just a bit wild in
it yeah it's just a bit wild
here's the thing right it's the fact
that like
you're you got an instructor telling you
how to Brack your back out for your for
your partner
as my here's the thing about I don't I
wouldn't send my girl to it but if my
girl was going to a class like that I
wouldn't have no complaints about it got
it
it's a little bit I think it's more the
Modern Woman there's there's that
difference between a modern Woman and
women that was before like now and
everything is social media everything is
in your face to say this is what you
have to do and This is Gospel
um would I do it as a woman as a 36 year
old woman probably not because I
probably like a you know an idiot and I
wouldn't want to embarrass myself but in
order to do that some people look at it
it's like oh I can make money to make
sure I can let other women feel this is
the way you're meant to be as a woman so
I also think it's a reflection of what
we as women think is valuable nowadays
like yeah we think that our value a lot
of it comes from sex and being
attractive and that goes back to why
this is happening going viral and not
finishing school because we've got this
perception that guys primarily like us
or our only value to get a guy to commit
comes from oh we get in bed and are we
attractive enough and how quick can you
do it yeah yeah when at least in my
opinion quality men don't value that as
don't value that as much as a girl who
goes to you know finishing school and
knows how to play the role of the
feminine in a relationship yeah well
because to guys like that like there's a
million girls that can that can do that
yeah yeah go ahead what's interesting to
me is the number of people in the club
like they've got some really good
marketing going on there I will say that
that's your point is that I don't need
it like what is is I mean that guy there
don't look doesn't he doesn't look like
he should be in that club
[Music]
but do you think it's more embarrassing
for the woman or the man because you
never know can the man be feeling
embarrassed in that video right now
because he hasn't said anything
the guy he's lying down I think it's
more embarrassing for the woman but she
doesn't know it
do you think though yeah yeah because
I just think like that's that's trashy
like yeah
I just think that's trashy and like if
you want to have a family someday like
that's gonna be on the oh yeah forever
yeah and so even if you don't have kids
now if you want to have kids someday
like that that's your mom like you as a
man like want that to be a girl but for
example if that was a future husband
that you found and he was beneath that
woman would you feel way
um how do I put it I mean I want to do I
want the guy I'm married to be under
like no no
but but I don't think it holds the same
weight cause I just think men and women
are different and so like to me it's
like oh I mean he's probably young and
just you know on wild [ __ ]
in relation to that argument it's like
yo you you were under this beautiful
woman but at the same time you would
just stay in a class in front of a whole
bunch of people I would have a lot I
would have a lot of questions
I would be like what was this
question is who's it who's it for who
are the ladies doing it for are they
doing it for their husbands their
partners are they doing it for fitness
and aerobic well I don't think they're
doing it for fitness and aerobics even
if it's what they tell themselves like
sure people need this logical reason to
like justify why they do things if they
wanted to get fit they would go to the
gym lift some weights do some cardio it
wouldn't be there so I do think that
they're doing this because they want to
get better at sex which it's not a
problem in itself like if you want to
put in the effort to be better and bad
for your man then amazing but it's more
so what does it show when women value
this over working on the substance do
you think most women know how to keep a
man outside of sex
um
to some extent no
what are you guys think in your your
experience dating absolutely not
the time I'm looking around the room
like yeah yeah cool but no not at all uh
um
they haven't got the
it's it's the competition that annoys me
because I feel like they're trying to
compete with us yeah rather than join
the team right you know what I'm saying
there's only one quarterback on the NFL
team right
I think more women are trying to be like
men with the masculinity yeah 100
um I think what I think what Hannah said
is really on on the money like
being of substance is really important
to high quality men and a lot of women
don't have that substance but they have
good looks good physiques Etc but what's
beneath the layers what where's the
substance behind it because that's in
essence what what men look for isn't it
yeah yeah and and to bounce off your
point I feel like what men look for is
that substance but what women come with
is materialistic right do you know what
I'm saying I want a man with a nice car
a nice house a nice day all is that all
of that you gotta earn six figures
the longest long since King Kong right
do you know what I mean where can you
take me how much all of that but if I if
I walk up and be like yo I was a I was a
pastry chef and I know how to make every
food underneath the Sun
that that substance in in terms of its
value is worthless if I don't have any
Financial money to back it up you know
what I'm saying so you're expecting oh
you're a chef so you should know you
should take me to Nobu or to cover that
meal for a lot less I'm about to pay for
it right I mean and you can do those
things but it's about having the the
woman having the substance to be able to
have that supported long term because a
lot of women will have will have good
looks and they'll attract a high quality
man that they like and pay attention to
Etc but the question is can you sustain
it and you can only sustain it if you
have substance underneath of the good
looks that you already possess as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible